vous en aurez de me dire ce que vous
fichez premier le dark dog candyland
vous êtes sûr que c'était sans la nommer
il m'a dit qu'il s'agit de deux jeunes
femmes au do fouetter qui parle allemand
s'il faut en général se garder d'être
optimiste dans ce cas ci on peut être
raisonnablement autres bandits ne te
laisse pas emporter par ton désir de
vengeance
tu perds de vue le but de notre visite
moi je perçois tu es tout et je trouve
cesse de te mettre comme des gardons je
veux pas me mettre dans dix ados ce que
je veux c'est l'intrigué commence à en
injuriant ces pauvres esclaves
je me souviens d'un homme qui m'a forcé
à tuer un père devant son garçon et qui
n'a pas sourcillé
vous vous en souvenez bien évidemment
que je m'en souviens et alors vous avez
dit c'est ça mon monde et donc monde
faut salir les mains
alors je fais pareil je me salit les
mains